this office bag doesn't contain file
folders newspapers in a lunch box
it holds the portable trans PC LCD 286 a
fully functional portable computer
weighing in at only 29 pounds unfolded
plug it in and go to work at the office
at home or in the field your office is
where you want it to be with a built-in
five and a quarter inch disk drive that
can hold 1,700 typed pages it's like
carrying your file cabinet with you
outstanding graphics on the
state-of-the-art LCD screen can be
adjusted for any lighting situation
powered by the latest 286 chip and the
power of 64 kilobytes of RAM this is one
hell of a Productivity machine who needs
to spend more on a brand-name Compaq the
portable trance comes loaded with
popular third-party application software
a word processor and calculator in a
slate gray finish it looks sleek and
modern your office in a bag send us
pictures of your favorite retro gadgets
in the comments and please subscribe to
the wire channel